for more on the deal and how it's
breaking down we've got Paul Sweeney of
Bloomberg intelligence and Bloomberg's
own Alex Sherman who broke this deal
early on this has been really a two-year
saga and here we are but it's not a done
deal it's not a done deal they're gonna
have to make the case to regulators now
and that's what we expect Tom Rutledge
he already started talking about it we
heard a brief soundbite from him just a
little while ago that's gonna be the
case that he's going to need to make
over the coming months why there is a
public benefit to this deal where there
wasn't one
when Comcast tried to buy time what's
the argument well I think the argument
they're gonna try to make in terms of
what's the public benefit for the FCC is
that listen we are in a new business
here the pay TV business is undergoing
tremendous amount of competition right
now from the who lose and the Netflix of
the world and the CBS is new HBO is
everybody going direct to the consumer
over the internet that really is a
threat to the core pay TV business the
response from the industry is they have
to continue to invest in their
programming they have to continue to
invest in the technology their broadband
plant they have to continue to make
these upgrades so I think they're going
to try to argue that listen we need to
get bigger we need to get scale to
compete in this new world so we'll see
if that you know works better than what
Comcast and for what it's worth they're
taking questions about this very issue
on the conference call and Charter says
a they anticipate a faster regulatory
review than Comcast under when Comcast
is really dragged on and B they're gonna
have less than 30 percent of the
high-speed broadband market which was
for the FCC an issue when it came to
Comcast and we know that FCC Chairman
Tom wheeler has already spoken to the
CEO of charter and the CEO of Time
Warner Cable Rob Marcus and basically
indicated to them just because we
rejected the Comcast deal doesn't mean
we're gonna reject all cable deals
that's a pretty strong sign I think that
he's open to a deal they didn't have
some sort
I'm not saying a wink wink nod nod but
some sort of legitimate signal that yes
we're possibly open for business after
seeing what just happened they would not
enter into this and to submit that point
there's a two billion dollar break fee
associated with this deal one more time
a two billion dollar breakup okay so it
wasn't and exactly what that means yeah
just walk us through it because this is
always below
if the deal falls apart charter pays
Time Warner Cable to billion dollars
how does that even happen why what is
the rationale behind that it regulatory
for the most part amazing now in this
case there might be another bid there
might be another bid from Altice
theoretically this other company that
jumped into the cable world the United
States two weeks ago ten days ago two
billion dollars doesn't that seem a
little Austin Powers - it's a massive
number in the context of a seventy-five
billion dollar total enterprise value
not that big a deal but I think it just
goes to show like there wasn't a break
up deal a breakup fee and a Comcast deal
because the risks were just so enormous
here but but here is highly motivated to
get this it get this deal done and I
think they're gonna clearly get the deal
done they they don't own any programming
they're much smaller than Comcast so I
mean I think this deal probably gets
done but there's there are several
fascinating aspects to this deal but one
that really caught my eye this morning
and one that from what I understand was
not expected is the participation of
hedge funds as finance ears three hedge
funds Jenna run by Barry Rosenstein a
soroban run by Eric Weinstein it's
company I don't know that much about and
Felina fondant class who are lining up
with Malone right buying shares of
Liberty broadband Liberty broadband of
course then helping to fund charters why
now these guys just have so much money I
think so I think part of the deal is
there's all there's been a lot of
private equity out there chasing deals
and in the private equity world loves
cable they love cable because it's high
free cash flow very predictable for free
free cash flow the question is why would
Malone let new equity come into this
deal we also Eric from Philippe lafon
standpoint we knew there was going to be
a shift in the way he was investing we
heard that from him what eight nine
months ago that he was going to go out
out of the simple public equity markets
and become much more much he's doubling
down he already owns according to the
latest filing charter shares and now
alright hello and charter shares through
this convoluted vehicle of Liberty
broadband that Sean Malone has if you
want liquidity right invest in charter
that stock trade yes if you don't need
liquidity maybe Liberty broadband is a
better vehicle it's the holding company
now for all of Malone's cable tell
NASA right that's not true of course
today it's much more thinly traded
exactly right this is something that
Malone has historically done over the
years is really create either tracking
stocks or just put assets and different
vehicles so investors can invest only in
what they want however it's all tax
driven does he ever get anything wrong
Malone he got this wrong he stumbled
into this deal honestly I mean they
really messed this up thought of
candidly Charter did back in 20 of
January of 2014 when they put out an
offer of one hundred and thirty two
fifty Time Warner Cable said they wanted
one hundred and sixty Charter didn't
meet meet it and Comcast went over the
top and bought the whole thing now
Chargers paying one hundred ninety five
dollars this year so now granted Charter
stock has also gone up quite a bit
instead so that sort of makes the VAT
another books in cash is still a hundred
bucks in cash and it could go all the
way up to 115 this office so so yeah I
mean he stumbled into this deal that the
key holders of this the shareholders
have an option to accept either a
hundred dollars and more charter stop
we're all the way up two hundred and
fifteen dollars and less charter stock
depending on what they want an
interesting tidbit to this deal
extraordinary great story